what are you afraid of I'm scared that
I'll fail at the goal then you can judge
how successful you were by how much you
adhered to the actions that you
committed
to so I run a writing company I write
for celebrities and CEOs because I took
your advice and I started writing for
people that have more money and it's oh
gosh solve rich people problems they pay
better yes um but I also publish my own
books and I traditionally published with
Publishers and I've done well but in the
future going forward I want to publish
my own book self-publish my own books
but I have analysis paralysis because
there's so many options to execute a
strategy sometimes I don't know which
option to pick to just execute the
strategy for my next book and my first
goal is just to sell a thousand ebook
copies not nothing even Grand yeah okay
then when I settle on a strategy I get
scared because I don't know if it's
going to work so two questions real
quick so when you say you have so many
different strategies you can pick from
you're talking about different topics
for the book is that what you're saying
I know the book topic but different
options to execute a plan so I could use
Quick clickfunnels to execute a plan to
sell a thousand cop yeah just selling it
yeah just selling a thousand copies
that's that that's my goal I want to be
able to sell a thousand copies for my
next self-published book have you read
the book yet have you written the book
yet no but the book will be that's the
easy part okay I'm a writer so that's
the easy part okay okay okay yeah you're
asking the universe for a guarantee
that it will never give you and you're
waiting for a response in order to move
forward from a universe that stays
silent and so you're just talking to
dead people um and waiting for a
response so like um the thing is is the
person you should be talking to is the
marketplace because they will always
respond like when you knock they will
open the door and they will tell you to
[__] off or they you open the door and
they'll tell you they'll let you in but
either way they'll open the door right
let's play this out the other way what
are you afraid of cuz like you seem very
upbeat and you see like obviously WR
this you've written stuff before and so
like I'm not worried about your writing
skill given what you've said so far so
like what are you afraid of okay so
let's let's play it out so let's say you
you have your book and you pick path one
it doesn't even matter what it is pick
path one okay so what so what happens so
you put it on Amazon you're like I'm
just going to put it on Amazon and see
what happens all right that's the easy
path okay then what yeah I'm I'm scared
that I won't reach my number I'm scared
that I'll fail at the goal and then then
what happens but then I still won't know
how to do it like and and I'm also
scared because I have self-published a
couple books in the past that didn't
reach my goal and I know that feels like
I don't want to feel like that again
yeah so let me so let me do this then
let's reframe this because I have a lot
of experience with setting goals all
right so I feel pretty confident talk
about the topic make the big goals that
you set things that you could absolutely
control like you cannot control how many
people buy your book but you can control
the amount of actions that you're
willing to take that make it
unreasonable that you don't sell a th000
copies and so then you can judge how
successful you were by how much you
adhered to the actions that you
committed
to and so if I were to say you have to
sell 10,000 books not a thousand books
10,000 books you have to or you lose
your life in 12 months you just die
that's it you die what would you do
knock on every door okay you have the
leads book right you there all there's
eight different ways to advertise right
and so you know that the more people
find out about your stuff the more
people buy it and you know there's only
four things you can do right you can
talk to people oneone you can make
content you can run ads right or you can
get other Affiliates you can get
referrals once they read your book or
you can get agencies or you can get
employees to help you out that's what
you got yeah okay and so if you know
that you have to take those
actions then wouldn't success be so
let's play this out a year let's say
that you did absolutely everything on
the plan like your plan of advertising
of letting people know about it for a
year and you did everything and you sold
999 bucks would you consider it a
failure no that would be a win okay now
if you sold 90 books I just want to
reframe this because the honestly the
thing that you're talking about is
something that so many people deal with
and it's because you want to control
things you want to control the outcome
and you're saying I'm only willing to
pay this price if there's this outcome
but you're seeing the outcome as the
outcome rather than the skills that you
develop along the way as the outcome
because I can promise you this this will
not be the the last book you write right
and so if you get to a hundred sales
instead of a thousand mhm
then what's going to happen
realistically is that you will figure
out the one thing or two things that
actually work to sell books and then
I'll say do a hundred times more of that
and you can either choose to do that on
this book or you can choose to do it on
the next book but the idea of like I
have I'm setting this thousand because
you could have said a million books it
doesn't really matter you're just
setting it you're making up a number and
saying this I feel is reasonable for me
but instead of making the number
reasonable make the actions that would
lead to that the reasonable like what
can you commit to four hours a day of
promotion
yeah okay then make that the commitment
and I will I'll promise you that if you
do that every day one at the end of the
year you will feel accomplished because
you actually did what you said you were
going to do and I will tell you that the
marketplace will also always recognize
someone who puts four hours of work
every single day into one thing just
what I needed thank you just promise me
that you'll actually just commit to
doing the work if you do that you do
like I have to get sell 10,000 books
what would I actually do to do that yeah
yeah find somebody who has an audience
that is relative to the the topics that
you're talking about and reach out to
that now it's okay if I got one person
they sold 20 books okay how do I reach
out to a thousand people who all have my
audience if you do that you'll probably
sell more than a thousand
books but you just got to do it four
hours every day thank you thank you good
luck with the book I know how much work
goes into that so I have two topics that
uh I kind of want to you know trade with
you and you know you titled this advice
for hard days and it's been it's been
tough lately about three months ago uh
my grandmother was diagnosed with cancer
two months ago uh my girlfriend the the
girl that I thought with I was going to
marry kind of left and then two weeks
ago uh I traveled to London to speak at
Europe's biggest business event and on
the first day of my arrival my granddad
passed away and so uh I had to basically
uh speak in front of thousands of people
and keep my smile and then travel back
and bury him so yesterday I I did I did
I did all of it and so the question is
well you know yesterday everything just
kind of hit me because now I'm back in
the office and I'm taking the calls and
I'm trying to deal with everything but
the question is how do I maintain my
composure and kind of stay strong right
because it's it's a tough period well
first off I'm sorry that you're going
through that um that being said honestly
you've got a lot of good stuff going for
you so this is a I feel like almost a
relatively easier one for me to take
given what you just said like you just
asked a question how do I do something
I've already done before which is you
got in front of thousands of people and
gave a presentation and had a smile and
you crushed it despite the fact that you
had other circumstances right yeah and
so you ask the question how do I do
something that I already
done you've already done it like what
you're saying is how do I how do I keep
living and you keep living by keeping
living it's the same thing with breakups
right it's like I I've heard this quote
I I heard it from Lea I think the first
time like the amount of time it takes
you to get over someone do you know how
long it is there's a math equation for
it there's a great math equation for it
you'll love it it's exactly as long as
you decide it takes and what I'm going
to say is going to sound really dark
right now so I want you to take this the
right way take it the way I mean it all
right which is that you just had you had
three deaths right you had death of a
life that you thought you were going to
have with a girlfriend and then you had
the death of uh two different
grandparents right you had three deaths
but well um on the positive sides my my
grandmother is still battling with it oh
okay she's still B wait we're plus one
all right so only two deaths now but
sure we can even play it out all right
on a long enough time rizon she will
eventually pass away right it's going to
happen yeah and the thing is is that you
are already standing it like you're
asking how do I stand it but you are
standing here already like you are
evidence to the F you are you you
talking to me today is evidence of the
success that you're asking asking for
you're already one dude you're showing
up and you're working every day you're
coming here to ask questions to actually
still trying and grow yourself like the
the stuff that you go through become the
stories that you will someday tell and
no one likes epic Heroes without Epic
monsters and so you have to go through
the rocky cut scene you have to have
those periods of time where you doubt
yourself well everyone else doubts
yourself where the walls are crumbling
around you because have you ever read
shoe dog fil knight story about Nike
even if you haven't the entire story is
just him getting kicked in the nuts for
30 years that's the whole story and then
he's like oh yeah and then I built Nike
right and now if he had just said yeah
um I started this company and everyone
loved it and all my suppliers were on
time and I just scaled straight and as
the money came in I just bought more
inventory and then we just went public
no one would care because it's not
relatable and the thing is is that when
you die the only thing that will remain
is the story that people will tell of
you and so wouldn't you want that to be
an epic story yeah and so the things
that you're going through are required
for the person you want to be and for
the goals that you have and how you are
acting in the present already proves the
thing that you're claiming that you want
tomorrow you're going to wake up and you
go to
work and the next day you're going to
wake up and you're go to work and then
you're going to text and it's going to
say that your grandmother's cancer is
getting worse and what are you going to
do you're going to get back to work
you're just going to keep doing the
stuff like there's no there's no magic
bullet you just keep going because
either you keep going or you
die yeah and if you don't die you
succeeded I would just say stop just
don't judge yourself on how you feel
judge yourself by what you do despite
how you feel so you can feel shitty you
can wake up and have a terrible day and
still show up with a smile in front of a
thousand people and so if you can do
with a thousand people you can do it
with one and that first one is the
person that looks at you in the mirror
in the morning and and now when it comes
to business I just have a real quick
question okay uh so I've built an
Instagram audience to over a 100,000 I
speak about sales and marketing uh I've
been doing it for the past two years
I've been posting kind of like every day
uh I know the content game but the one
thing that I'm struggling to balance is
you know how you say give give give
until they ask and you know I love it
but sometimes it takes a while until
they ask right and cash flow still needs
to come in and I run uh a service based
uh business and so how do I balance it
out without tiring my audience because I
also my community is known for you know
really being in the comments chatting
with me and being there for me so how do
I do it so if you want to have a one
step away from like just giving forever
right is that you you give in public
sell in private which is when people
respond to your stories right when
people DM you like those are
conversations that they're usually
asking or they're like they're basically
ask when people ask questions there you
can still Define a scope and say hey
like at at a certain point I have like
I've given you all this value use all
the free stuff if you want more than
that I'd be happy to hop on a call and
see if I can help you more right so it's
not it's not like everyone buy this
thing right now right you're not you're
not like getting super aggressive about
you still publicly just keep pumping all
the Goodwill and the value that you are
and that'll grow your audience and it'll
increase goodwi and all of those things
that's what you want you're going to
keep doing that it's just that you could
still have a call to action that's just
in the in the in the comment section or
put a story up that says hey by the way
if you need help with that thing I'm I'm
happy to help like those are those are
very light touch things cuz I understand
you got to pay bills I understand that
and so you can put those things out
without necessarily damaging the
Goodwill that I think you're that you're
that you're obviously building to hang
in there you'll be fine you'll get
through it and then it'll be a story
that you'll someday tell yeah and thank
you for everything that you do not just
for me but for everyone else because I
think you're marking A New Path uh and
that's that's kind of cool I appreciate
you br thank you what's the one question
that you wish you would have asked
yourself earlier in your entrepreneurial
career when faced with a little bit of
uncertainty and Direction 90% of my
business is in person online that's the
kind of the the direction of whether or
not I really want to go towards um more
specifically you know creating almost
like a watify version of kettle bells
just trying to figure out what the next
step is going to be so me asking myself
a question is always going to be
different than you asking something for
you because we're different people right
and we have different goals and so
everything usually Lads up to like
what's the goal what's the why and so
like right now do you have like a
monetary goal do you have an impact goal
and believe me I have no issues if
you're like I just want to make a
certain amount of money like I get that
because any of the businesses that you
just mentioned so whether it's the brick
and mortar uh business or you want to
start doing training for those people
online or it's doing the watify version
which is basically no service and just
providing workouts and whatnot all of
those are are potential businesses but
pursuing all of them at the same time
will virtually guarantee that you don't
succeed at any of them and so the
biggest issue when you're starting out
is just pick the path and being willing
to commit to it with the uncertainty
that comes with it because like every
entrepreneurial path has uncertainty
like and that's what makes
entrepreneurship hard it's literally the
not knowing and the pain of suffering
consequences for ignorance for things
that you've learned now that you're like
if I had only known then what I know now
and that's every entrepreneur until the
day they die and it's just wishing that
it were different that causes a lot of
the struggle so which of these things of
the three that I just mentioned like
which of those is the one that like
lights you up the most I mean iners
training obviously like we live in a
small Beach toown Community where
everybody knows everybody and it's fun
it's family it's convenient I will say
there's that comfort factor that it
almost in one scope is very beneficial
because it is so comfortable but in
reality too like Comfort is the enemy of
achievement and growth so it's like I
know like the comfortable side is the
inperson and it's the community and it's
fun it's family friends whereas the
uncomfortable more challenging but also
very big picture-wise would be the
online going Full Tilt that side now i'
I've breached into the gap of like
three-day launches four day launches of
you know small ticket low ticket offers
but in terms of you know trying to scale
and make an impact on the world the
world's really big that so that's always
really hard because I remember I had a
we had an event with Jim owners and
somebody stood up I said what's your
mission they're like I want to impact 1
Million Lives I was like dude you have a
brck and morar location that has like
200 members like let's like if you
really want to do that then you would
actually just you would you you would
you would approach it very differently
or you'd have a Time rise and that's the
rest of your life right it's like one or
the other if you're like I want to do
that in 3 years you wouldn't start with
a brick and mor location and so the
thing is is that what you said earlier
is like you you feel comfortable and it
sounds like you want to grow I just want
to make sure that's correct before I
like keep going okay so there there was
like an underlying assumption at least
that was unspoken and I just want to
draw attention to it which was you're
like the brick and mortar thing is
comfortable it's family it's friendly
it's fun I'm assuming it's profitable
I'm assuming you're making some money
doing that the thing is is like you
could like just doing more of what
you're currently doing and saying like
how do I open a second location or how
do I you know like how do I open like
locations over the next 5 years or
whatever it is that would produce
probably just as much of a challenge as
going online would except you already
have two years of learnings on how to
run that business where you have none in
the online space you always just want to
Stack knowledge within a specific
vertical so that you just go deeper and
deeper on it because that's where the
compounding returns happen like the
richest people that I know have been in
the same space for 40 years they just
know everything there is to know about
the space and like that's how they've
made their money you can either open a
location that's not necessarily in a
beach down and test your metal and see
how good you are at actually scaling a
team you know hiring somebody else
seeing if somebody else if you can
actually incentivize people build a
culture so that people want to work for
you that you can recreate the success
and that'll show you whether the success
that you had was because of you or
because of your ability as a as a
businessman right because like you can
be a charismatic razzled Dazzle dancing
bear in any brick-and mortar business
and it will
work it'll work surface with a smile
always works right and it's just hard to
scale because most people don't care as
much as owners do but if you can create
the model that has the incentives and
the training in place and the and the
procedures that can consistently create
that five out of five experience that
allow a second location to have the same
amount of success as your first location
then you have something that absolutely
can scale and create lots of Enterprise
Value over time so I would say either
scale that or basically dial down your
iners to as little ass humanely possible
of your time and then go all in on the
online thing but uh trying to do both
will be very hard because what'll happen
is you'll start to do some online stuff
you'll start to see some traction your
gym will start going down but that's
your main source of income then you'll
hop back to the gym the online will dip
and you'll go back and forth and so
that's why I'm so big on just committing
to whatever thing is because any of them
would work but you just have to be all
in on it the one pillar that I guess I
failed to mention was the freedom and
flexibility this being a seasonal town
where I'm at it's like being able to
essentially create a life where it
allows me to own and be at the brick and
mortar for say four months out of a year
and then from there being able to live
elsewhere and then from there because at
the end of the day I don't have much
responsibility here aside from the just
just the gym I don't have anything else
really that's Tim me to home but that's
where I guess my my North Star has been
for a long period of time let me just
give you step one here I own a ton of
brick and mortar locations as is like
right now I've got 70 stores that I own
between different companies that are
brick and mortar locations I'm not in
any of them and so like the idea that
you need to go online in order to not be
in person is a fallacy that's not true
like you can own your gym because like
if you were to open a second location
you wouldn't be there either right and
so the easiest way to test this 1.0 test
is like if you can step out and just not
go to the gym for a year then maybe you
can do the other thing and if you
haven't gone to the gym for a year then
maybe you'll do the you'll do a second
gym and so I think no matter what path
you do this is probably a perfect end
for this which is you either are going
to do the online thing after you figure
out how to Outsource gym or delegate it
and hire people who are awesome or you
decide you're going to do a second
location either way you're going to have
to start with Outsourcing the first gym
let's say I um I want to start a
business I can have a very Grand Vision
of the business so like apple or
Microsoft they they had this vision of
like changing the whole world how do we
keep working on this business for years
when we're worried that it might get
outdated because of a new AI or a
technology or in other words what do we
do when we think our project might not
be useful in the long run I mean what
you're talking about is strategy like
these are strategic decisions that we
have to make like you make a big bet on
where you think the market is going to
be not where it is today if you're going
to go after something that's that big
but do do you have investors right now
I'm I'm a entrepreneur if you you say
that if you look at the companies that
you just referenced right like you look
at basos with Amazon you look at you
know Zuckerberg you look at Microsoft
every one of those guys started well off
and well capitalized okay so basos was a
investment banker from Wall Street Bill
Gates parents were really well off and
he was well off and whatnot Zuckerberg
went to Harvard same deal you if you
want to really go after that you would
have to try and recreate the conditions
and I think that right now the
likelihood that that happens given your
current situation is low and I'm not
saying that to disuade you I'm saying
because I want to be realistic with you
which is that you need to get your own
head above water cuz like right now if
you're if you don't have the ability to
make money on your own right from a
entrepreneurial perspective like you
need to get your head above water
because the only way that you can stick
with something for the required amount
of time in order for it to become world
changing like we're not talking even a
decade I mean those companies they're
you know 20 Facebook's 20-some years old
right just like context and so the only
way to get there uh is be able to
breathe while you're going and so I
think that from a a one-on-one
perspective starting starting a simple
business that you can generate income on
that you know you can you can learn the
basics of business before trying to take
on the biggest competitors in the most
well capitalized Arena absolutely on
your own I see not to say that that's
impossible it's just incredibly
improbable given the the circumstances
that you just laid out it would be
really romantic for me to be like dude
go chase your dreams go do that but like
I also would rather have you in a year
making money on your own so that you can
breathe because you might find out that
if you actually start making on money on
your own you might just like that
because right now it's just the idea of
the status of the dream of that like
it's an amorphous idea but the amount of
pain and suffering that you have to be
able to put up with and not make money
through that whole period of time really
tough wouldn't that cause another issue
where because you you decide to choose a
pro choose to solve a problem that is
small like smaller than the Grand Vision
uh then you won't be able to scale much
that's not necessarily true and also
every one of those company start small
like Facebook wasn't like we want to be
the social media platform for the whole
world he wanted to map colleges s they
start with a niche and then they expand
outwards and so you would want to much
more narrowly Define your problem before
you go attack it because what you're
going to try and do is build something
that's going to be everything for
everyone and it's going to be nothing
for nobody strategy is prioritization
it's allocating limited resources
against unlimited options and so you
have unlimited options but you have very
limited resources and so in order to be
successful you have to narrow the
problem that you're trying to solve so
you can allocate the small amount of
resources you have to adequately solve
that problem completely and then from
adequately solving that problem
completely like Amazon started with
books and Facebook started with colleges
right you solve and then you can go
adjacent right so right now it just
sounds exciting to say this but like
it's not reality you have to pick one
problem that you're going to get really
good at solving and that's it and then
you can have an idea that in the future
but real real so many things are going
to change between now and then and
there's so much luck that that that has
to concur because if you think about
this zooming all the way out the biggest
companies the world have super well
capitalized people who are the best in
the world made a good call and had luck
because if you're number one you have
all the things plus luck like if you're
number one at like in the whole world
it's all of it plus luck the market
moves in a direction that that you never
know right and so I would rather you
just stick to a problem that you know
you can absolutely solve given the
resources you have learn the skills make
income and then from there you can go
solve an adjacent problem or you might
decide you know what I like this and I'm
going to keep going with it thank you
very much that's that was really awesome
you're on good luck man all right so my
question is basically I've been an
online fitness coach for the last like
three years now and like even
progressing from like the first 10K a
month like three years ago and like 25k
a month a couple months ago I kind of
felt like I got loner the more
successful I got even though I do have a
pretty big audience now like maybe you
went through something that something
like that or maybe you haven't in that
sense I was just wondering like maybe
how you got over that self liim belief
because I feel like that's kind of
holding me back I want to make sure that
I'm I want to clearly understand your
question so you're saying that being
lonely is the thing that is holding back
I know my lifestyle changes oh obviously
you're going to lose friends along the
way the conversation is a lot different
in that sense but just like especially
from going in person and being a
full-time in person training and going
line top of that just like a lot more
lonely can in a lot of different aspects
of losing that kind of touch you just
need you just have to join a community
man like just straight up like you just
need you just need to get around people
who are doing the same thing as you and
so that might mean physically moving to
a different area cuz right now I'm
assuming online pay like pays your bills
correct yeah right so if online pays
your bills then you can literally be
anywhere in the world and so if you
where do you live right now I'm Emon
Alberta I'm planning to move to Colona
it's more of like a fitness town in
Canada like two months time I would do
that and I would also join a bunch of
online communities of people who are
like trying to make money in the fitness
space because you'll find a ton of other
people who are doing the same thing as
you that are on the path that are ahead
of you they're the same as you that are
behind you and you you can get a little
bit of some some fulfillment from
helping out some of the people behind
you but you can also get help from the
people ahead of you um who are you know
because you show that you'll you'll
execute and you'll do what they say um
and you'll and you'll grow but this is
the nice news is that this problem is
super solvable like you just got to get
around people and you got to be willing
to be rejected I mean it's just like
Fitness sales it's just like friend
sales it's the same thing you just go
you go you go on a bunch of dates
they're just friend dates you know go
hang out go get a lift in I mean it's
Fitness so like just go ask a bunch of
people to get a lift in and you'll see
who's cool and you'll see who isn't
worst case scenar you get a workout yeah
have you ever kind of experienced that
as a kind of leveled up and leveled up I
know you as long as you keep growing
this is not going to stop you're going
to find new friends and if you keep
growing you'll pass them and then you'll
find new friends that are above them and
you'll pass them and you'll just keep
going um and so it just depends on how
like what you see the role of friends as
in your life and so you know for me I
just want my requirement for friend
isn't necessarily that they make the
same or more money than me at all is do
they make me better do they make me
better do they have my best intentions
in heart which is already two incredibly
difficult things to pass but if someone
passes both those things then they are a
friend and so I would just use that as a
limit test like is this person making me
better and do they have my best you know
incentive at heart yeah and how is
making friends I guess now because
obviously you're a higher level and
things are different with social status
and all that I mean vers four it's
probably different so do kind of have
the same standards now are kind of like
what is what is it kind of like dude
it's harder for me than it is for you
yeah right um no for real it is but the
thing is is that uh most of the my
closest friends don't live here like
don't live in the same physical area
that I do most of the closest friends
that I have live all over and so I see
most of my friends once or twice a year
and that's it and I work in the meantime
the thing is is that like the higher up
you go here like and I'll just tell you
something like from My Level whatever
you want to call that um all the friends
I have everyone completely like there
are zero social obligations for
anything like none and if I don't
respond to a text for 3 days there is
zero drama it's not even acknowledged
it's just we know that busy people
understand that busy people are doing
[__] and so if everyone you have
everyone who's who's in your world
understands that you're trying to take
this hill then if they're truly your
friend then they want you to take the
hill more than they want you to respond
to their text or come out with them for
the weekend like I just got invited to a
7-Day thing that um with a with a couple
friend that Lea and I both really really
adore um but we'll probably not be able
to do it because we have so much stuff
that we were that we doing at that same
time and I really want to go but I also
really want to do this other stuff and I
know that I will feel worse about myself
if I don't have this other stuff done
and so we're going to say that I can't
go and that's going to be it and they're
not going to hold it against
me and so until you find friends who are
100% aligned with you achieving your
goals who are making you better and want
you to hit your goals then you just keep
looking
but the thing is like everybody goes
through the period that you're at like I
think I I think I made I wrote a tweet
about this but like there is this lonely
period that always happens when you
start growing because it happens is that
you're too big for the old friend group
but you're not quite big enough for the
group that you want to get into right so
you kind of have this path in the Middle
where you just kind of like keep
trudging along but like every single
person who's accomplished anything
material has been in your exact same
shoes and you just keep going and you
keep going you keep networking you enter
you go into the communities you see the
people who are adding value to those
communities and you message them you
find the givers cuz givers recognize
givers almost immediately you can see
the people who are always giving more
above and beyond and you can understand
they get the game and so like in that
first meeting if they're like like let
me see if I can do this for you let me
like take care of this for you let me
help you in this way rather than like
hey could you help me with this like
wrong person but if you just start by
giving to a whole bunch of people who
are where you want to be you'll get more
back even if nine out of 10 don't give
you anything back provide shitloads of
value people will message you and they
be like hey let's hop on a zoom let's
grab a zoom lunch whatever and so like
you can have a ton of friend dates or
whatever that you meet people and see if
they have game and if they have game
then you keep in touch because you're
making them better too I appreciate
everything you bet brother kill the
content game [__] after doing full-time
entrepreneurship for three years right
um and you know raising a family I got
four four small children all under the
age of five I found myself in a very
hard position where I had to go back to
a 9 to-5 I would say entrepreneurship is
like like you said it's hard and and I
know what hard feels like but after
discussing it with my wife like I felt
like this was like the right decision
after getting myself into business dead
and other things like that
and I didn't never have a paycheck to
live on you know so how do I know when
it's like like how do I get back into
entrepreneurship like now I'm just
running my stuff on the Sid so for
example right when I was laid off uh
three years ago I was doing taxes and I
just doing like um bookkeeping and then
I worked my way up starting to offer
accounting services and then I leveled
up and I started look going after higher
levers like now I started doing CFO
services and um I went through that
Valley of Despair thing and that's
probably why I'm at where I'm at right
now you know okay um just being
completely honest and I I appreciate you
being hand in upfront about it cuz
otherwise this wouldn't be very valuable
cuz you'd tell me a bunch of fake
information and I'll give you a response
to fake information it wouldn't matter
for either of us so thank you for being
honest um that being said you're not
honestly you're in a pretty good spot
and I'll tell you why so you have a
valuable skill set that will always be
in demand because a lot of people don't
want to do money stuff so people don't
do budgets people don't do bookkeeping
people don't do CFO work people want to
do financials projections forecasts no
one wants to do any of that stuff and
you do and you're good at it so
presumably you're good at it because you
keep doing it right I'll just I'll I'll
leave it at that I'm going to assume
that for for the sake of our call right
so um one I think it was wise that you
got a job because you have a wife you
have four kids I think that was a smart
Noggin move okay now that being said
there's going to be a conversation that
you probably have to have with your wife
about what because your nights and
weekends either are going to have to go
to family or they're going to have to go
to the new thing and so I think that you
need to have a candy conversation with
her and say listen my Prim and I'm I'm
put I'm putting words in your mouth here
so this is if I were in your shoes I
would say as a man my primary drive is
to
provide and right now I feel like I'm
failing you and I want to lead our
children by example so that when they
are 20 or 30 and they're thinking about
making that jump I can speak to it
because I wasn't afraid to take the risk
again because in gymnastics as soon as
you fall off the pommel horse even if
you twist or break your ankle you what
they do they try and get you right back
on the horse again and they do that
because if you don't and you take enough
time off you start developing these
fears around getting back on you never
get on again and so they want you to get
back on the horse and right now I think
you got bucked by the entrepreneurial
horse and that's okay it happens it's
part of the game right like it's the
it's the the scene in Rocky 17 or
whatever [__] Rocky it is where he's
like it's not about how hard you can hit
about but it's about hard you can get
hit and keep going forward right and so
you got hit big you know big whoop
everybody gets hit everyone [__]
loses all the time I lost everything
twice before this time right and so like
you've lost everything once you still
you still owe me
one you can tell your wife I said that
and so let's get into tactics all right
so right now the in my opinion the issue
that you miss is you didn't know how to
advertise you didn't know how to promote
and so you have the service you just got
to let people know about it and so you
were full-time as an entrepreneur but
you probably weren't spending four hours
a day promoting and so when you are
you're 100% correct right and so that's
that's what need to do so nights and
weekends for you is you log out of work
go home kiss the dog high five the kids
and then you spend four hours promoting
and promoting is you make content you
reach out to people or you run ads and
given your financial situation it's
going to be making content and reaching
out to people that's it literally if
that's what you're you start your timer
four hours you make content you reach
out to people and you do that for four
straight hours every day you do that
you're going to have more business in
the next six months than you even know
know what to do with that's it that's
all you have to do like you the thing is
you're in a good spot cuz you have the
skill that there's already demand like I
don't have to test your idea you're
trying to provide bookkeeping services
it's a commoditized service like if you
do a good job you're on time like you
are responsive you deliver things on the
first of the month people will want to
do business with you and they'll stay
with you and so you just got to let
people know about it faster because I'm
guessing that your rate was based on
referrals you had one or two customers
maybe three and by the time you get one
new referral every two or three months
one would drop and you stayed there
until eventually you couldn't right I'm
guessing that was the story right so you
just need to increase your sales
velocity which means you got to let more
people know about it and you got to
learn how to sell because it was just
you right did you have any employees no
I had a virtual assistant during tax
season but yeah it was mainly just me
yeah then you have the easiest business
in the world because 100% of the revenue
is profit right it's just you for now
and so you can absolutely get yourself
to 10 20 accounting clients and you're
going to be working like a dog at this
point but you'll be making way more than
you are now and then you'll have new
problems cuz then your wife's like I
don't see you anymore you're like yeah
but now we're making three times money
and I will find a way to use the money
to buy back some time and you can do
that but idea like you're you're like
you already have the hard [__] done
you're like 6 months away seriously like
I don't normally say that like you're 6
months away you got to you got to reach
out to let's call it let's call it
10,000 people you reach out to 10,000
people you'll have you'll have the
business you want because I'm telling
you right now as a business owner dude
the amount of crappy accountants and
bookkeepers that out there outnumber the
good ones 100 to one like no one's
stoked about their book keeper so like
like it's not hard and like think about
it those guys don't like those guys
suffer the same issue that you have is
they don't know how to promote
themselves they're not business people
they're Bean counters and so like you
you've been you've been in bean counter
mode and you got to get in you got to
get in promoter mode especially as a as
a solo entrepreneur it's all promotion
in the beginning so would you suggest
just mainly cold Outreach or should I
try to do content or just go straight
cold Outreach you can do both I mean
dude one post a day one post a day see
who interacts with it so who likes it
who comments on it you can message all
those people and then you can reach out
as well but the thing is is with your
profession finding someone who has an
adjacent audience so uh you know if
someone who's an HR company or a
recruiting company right like if you can
figure out a way to just work with them
they already have a whole engine of
people coming in and just see if you can
just get off the backside and give them
a kickback just for intros like that's a
super productive way of uh of leveraging
the amount of reach outs like you can
just reach out to 10,000 business owners
and you'll you'll get your nut but you
could probably reach out to a th000 B2B
businesses and see if you can structure
a partnership with them that they can
refer you business and you refer it back
to them but yes content and Outreach you
and real talk the content is probably
not in the beginning where you're going
to get the majority of your business I
just want to just prepare you for that
but the reason that you're going to be
making the content in the beginning is
that so when you do Reach Out people
will go to your page and they will
consume your content and then they will
decide to
respond based on the quality so think
about that stuff as lead nurture more
than lead genen in the
beginning over time you'll get better at
it it'll start generating business but
it might take you a year or two like it
takes time to get good at that you've
inspired me and that's the reason why I
took the jump in the beginning so I
appreciate you well I appreciate you for
taking the jump and um I will ask you to
trust me one more time which is that
four hours a day have the conversation
with your wife 10,000 reach outs and let
me know in six months she's watching so
she knows all right let celese take his
10,000 reach outs that's it like on the
other side of 10,000 reach outs is you
making the money that you want to make
and having the skill of promotion and
sales that's it I just want you to know
and I and I hope that mation exists here
for this one reason which is that like
you are not alone there are other people
going through it and so despite that it
may feel lonely you are not
alone keep being one of zero